there is cautious optimism across
Nigeria as people wait for the final
official election results
voting took place in a few parts of the
country on Sunday with technical
glitches and isolated cases of violence
disrupted polls the day before
some of those who voted hope results
will be announced soon we should be able
to get the tools to make election free
fair and faster so that everybody
somebody like me can have 100 trust in
it and faithly that is going to reflect
our will for a betterment of our society
Nigeria's election process was marked by
a late start here in enugu in the
Southeast and other regions 18
presidential candidates want to lead
Africa's most populous nation but only
three are seen as having any chances of
winning
of the governing all progresses congress
former vice president atiku abubakar of
the main opposition people Democratic
party and former anambra State Governor
Peter Obi of the smaller labor party
whoever wins the presidency will have a
lot of challenges to deal with turning
around a struggling economy attacked by
armed groups in some regions cash
shortages as well as the High Cost of
Living
Nigerians also voted for
parliamentarians to represent them for
the next four years
if these elections don't go well
um you have a situation where we become
the burden for other nations will become
a destination for A.D destination for
help rather than play our party in
joining to contributing development
Nigeria is also struggling with a
separatist movement kidnappings for
ransom conflict between herders and
Farmers corruption poverty and
unemployment issues people here want
addressed urgently harumatasa alcazera
Nigeria